juli auf mich zum motten klughardt
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen blog auf einem kanal gemerkt und
ich rede schneller als sonst das liegt
nämlich ganz einfach daran dass nicht zu
einer ein stundenlohn change nominiert
wurde von dem lieben simon will bekannte
ex audi
diese einstellungen flop so bei diesen
stunden blogs stellen steht es nicht
darum dass man einen blog hochlädt wer
eine stunde lang geht sondern dass man
diesem problem anhoben und innerhalb von
einer stunde ab dreht das heißt ich hab
jetzt eigentlich nur noch 59 minuten
zeit
was man innerhalb dieser zeit machen
kann und da ist mir eingefallen ich muss
auch mal wieder zum ikea weil das bild
da vorne finde ich ein bisschen
langweilig und da will ich drei neue
hängen haben und die klassen 7 laden
nicht nur für möbel vertrat
das ist übrigens nicht bezahlt oder so
sondern ikea benennt ihre möbeln
wirklich sehr sehr komisch und sehr
lustig und damit kann man witzige
wortspiele machen das heißt juden ich
fahre jetzt zum ikea und ich werde
versuchen in einer stunde die sind doch
fertig zu machen dieser einen stunde so
viele dumme wortwitzig wie auch immer
mit die kerb begriffen wir müssen dahin
eher schnell ikea also versuchen wir
jetzt innerhalb von einer stunde oder
verrückt verbliebenen 40 minuten so
viele wortspiele mit ikea möbel namen zu
machen wie geht das gut
luca war es heute für die
nationalmannschaft packen ich wollte
heute für nacken und das war ja ein
guter gag netz die so geht die lampe
nicht auch die hatte schalte ich dachte
das wäre ein knackig bereitete die
wortwitz eigentlich fort neben machen
das eigentlich relativ spontan hier
stehen aber viele boxen das war wohl ein
relativ guter sammler oder unten gibt es
hot dogs von drei kinder das finde ich
aber schon ein bisschen dicker denn das
ist einfach so ein regal mit 2017 ps
stehen alter wo diese bambus lampen land
wirtschaftlich handwerklich oder etwa
industriell hergestellt was bedeutet
nein eigentlich nett ja du bist aber
auch ganz schön dumm alter wir sind gar
nicht in stockholm julia sag mal was sie
vergessen dass sie absolvierte die
komplette lautstärke und könnte dass das
nicht pushen niete dragons luca
das gibt mir schon nach etwas
hochklassigen aus das ist ein laptop
kein problem ich bringe dir nach hause
walter ist es herbst leute da kann es
mal herkommen
ich nehme die freiheiten meine beine ein
bisschen aufs sofa zu legen
ein hektar wie nennt man es wenn man
einen guten freund unterstützt zweck
büromöbeln eis alter das sofa jetzt
einfach eine schlaf punktion schillig da
kann sich das sofa aus kunst kann
allerdings auch sein dass du so viel
davon gar nichts versteht denn das sind
ja bett dinge spur
ich würde sagen wir nehmen die werden
das ist die beste box diese lampen
enthalten megageil für unsere küche aber
das problem ist die ganze zeit nur einen
monat im jahr dann haben
ich will ein bisschen matt mäßig liegt
so eine küchenwaage das ist jedoch die
ganze zeit acht mann muss drücken damit
es verhinderte 2017 ps aber 2012 ich es
geht auch ein bisschen zu warten ich
meine bin ich hier beim luxuskarossen
händler oder bei ikea was macht eine
waffe bringen eigentlich wollte ich den
sessel doch dann habe ich diesen see
gesehen und dachte mir das ist der
tollste kennt ihr das pokémons madboy
hier wie wir das mit bo heißen wenn ein
bisschen zu viel essen würde zb
[Musik]
du bist ein ganz schöner knipser
das ist das sehr praktisch in diesem
ordner finden die julis finanzen relativ
leer
[Musik]
wenn ein prominenter fallschirmspringen
macht was hofmann ihm hinterher aus dem
flugzeug leister was [ __ ] [ __ ] alter
geschlecht oder geschlechtsverkehr im
fisch hommel fig alter was erst tische
und jetzt auch noch die jetzt kriegt ja
noch ein anruf reinalter die muss
wahrscheinlich relativ bekannt sein
ach das ist doch der markus oder das
zufrieden mit der wand fahre morgen hast
du nur einen bentley ich habe mehrere
bretter auf mich zum motten ich finde
diese lagerung hier nicht nur super
sondern wirklich fantastisch man mit mir
nähe ich will das gern direkt mitnehmen
bis du interessiert den fußball näher in
gold nee ich steh grad im osten
du bist ja heute rostig unterwegs war
ist hier viel licht alter das ist schon
relativ ländlich hier werden müssen weil
sie einfach im ikea die haltestelle von
julians bus noch mal an
ok ich schon relativ luftig hier jule
das abendessen sieht ja schon relativ
smuggling auslass die korken knallen
freunde voll krass du kochst du vorne t
ich denke den tisch wir sind schon
heftige multitalente rudel ist das
einfach samstag
hier ist gar keine sondern habe ich
später golfspieler werde ich werde
fußballer wie david beckham albert
einstein krass dass man den ihr da kann
man ihm einfach nur ein kompliment
machen wo ist denn julia henke
leute ich liebe die prärie ist es bei
euch eigentlich auch so dass ihren
besten kumpel im sommer habt und halt
auch noch im winter gestoppt wir müssen
noch eben kurze rast machen
jule sei doch ein bisschen vorsichtig
weil du bist foul gegen dich doch da
nicht schon wieder an
lag es ja da hast du dein pokal ist das
romantisch grade wollen uns morgen
treffen jude
das ist zwei plus zwei ja das ist
richtig
juli das ist aber fabulös der top steht
hier nicht ganz drauf ich bin halt immer
mehr so der idealist ach ja du bist echt
der knaller wie heißt die schwester vom
sänger von sorry du siehst gerade echt
appetitlich aussehen wie wir sie nun
schon in einem quartal
[Musik]
disco dann sogar was machst du da gerade
ich war grad lokal gut morgen julia was
machst du da luca fda nicht gegen sorry
ich bin halt relativ billig neue hier
liegt einfach ein bumerang
jetzt liegen eigentlich zurück immer
willkommen im gerät doch mit mir so
viele verschiedene kerzen das ist ja
echt ein phänomen der mir diese ganzen
licht in der wohnung hätten wir endlich
mal klarheit
da wir jetzt gerade durch ein ganzes
jahr durch sind und erst bei 7 40
minuten sind würde ich sagen einfach
einen verrat an der stelle durch den
heutigen blog jetzt allerdings auf erden
meine damen und herren simon du hast mir
nicht leicht gemacht es regnet einfach
draußen als die angaben schienen liegen
würde lieber du hast es mir nicht leicht
gemacht aber ich dachte okay wenn ich
die zu ikea muss man sich ein paar
wortspiel dieses lauf konkreten fall
jedoch muss ich ja nur noch drei leute
dominieren die ebenfalls einen
kompletten block in nur einer stunde
abdrehen müssen als allererstes würde
ich meine freundin jule nominieren
die macht ja auch schon echt immer super
flott ist der sonntag das wetter ist
echt schön guckt euch das mal an die
isar will ich an zweiter stelle jona
nominieren
ein guter kumpel von mir und ein dritter
stelle würde ich max nominieren weil max
immer so ein bisschen unmotiviertes
videos zu machen das ist jetzt meine
aufgabe besteht aber auch drei andere
leute nominiert habe für diese challenge
würde ich den blog an dieser stelle
jetzt auch beenden weil viel mehr zeit
bleibt noch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
durch die challenge gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen leiter julia und ich
fahre jetzt nach hause und bauen diese
bilderrahmen hierauf also im nächsten
blog seht ihr dann hängende bilderrahmen
bei mir in der wohnung jetzt kommt
erstmal ist ruh
[Musik]